Dann hätte man für Deutschland eine Regelung, hätte keine regellose Regelung und die Länder, die das nicht regeln wollen, die haben dann die Bundesregelung und die Länder, die das regeln wollen, können dann das für sich regeln.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 123 und am Mikrofon, wie ihr es gewohnt seid, Tim Pritlove. Ja und heute bin ich mal wieder unterwegs und habe mich in Fernlande begeben, zumindest in für mich Fernlande. Bin von Berlin nach München gefahren, um hier einer Veranstaltung beizuwohnen, auf der sehr viele alte Computer zu sehen sind, aber um diese Veranstaltung geht es hier eigentlich nur am Rande. Denn ich wollte die Gelegenheit dieses Treffens nutzen, um mal einen ganz dedizierten Blick in die deutsche Hackergeschichte zu wagen. Ein weiteres Mal, muss ich sagen, die ist ja hier auch schon einige Male zur Sprache gekommen. Insbesondere ist dabei zu verweisen auf Ausgabe 77, die Tuva TXT-Folge, die sich so ein bisschen mit dem Gründungsmythos des Chaos Computer Club auseinandergesetzt hat. Vielleicht habt ihr auch schon reingehört, Ausgabe 100 hat sich ja auch so mit dieser spezifischen Hackerkulturgeschichte Anfang der 80er Jahre auseinandergesetzt. Aber in meinem Erwägen und Empfinden fehlte eigentlich dann auch immer noch so ein ganz bestimmter Teil, nämlich während so der ganze CCC-Kontext in der Regel sehr wohl bekannt ist und dadurch, dass der CCC auch heute noch so aktiv ist, wird da viel drüber geschrieben und berichtet, so auch hier. Aber es gab ja noch sein anderes gallisches Dorf, was sich damals mit den Technologien, die aufkamen, auseinandergesetzt hat und auch den dahinterstehenden politischen und gesellschaftspolitischen Fragestellungen. Das Ganze ist bekannt unter dem Projektnamen Die Bayerische Hackerpost und war ja ein kleines Informationsblatt. Und darum soll es heute gehen. Und ich freue mich, hier eine illustre Runde begrüßen zu können. Von links nach rechts begrüße ich erst mal Thomas Vogel. Jetzt musst du Hallo sagen. Genau. Hans, Franke habe ich auch noch mit an Bord. Und last but not least Norbert. Hallo, Norbert. Ja, ihr seid jetzt hier alle zusammengekommen. Anlässlich des, ich habe es schon erwähnt, Vintage Computer Festival, was auch schon zum zehnten Mal stattfindet. Was verbirgt sich dahinter?
Ja, das Vintage Computer Festival ist in gewisser Weise die hardware gewordene BHP. Das heißt, wo die BHP das Magazin für den lebensbejahenden DFÜ-Benutzer ist, ist das Vintage Computer Festival das Treffen für den lebensbejahenden Althardware-Benutzer.
Verstehe, es steht also sozusagen alles im Kontext. Du organisierst das ja, Hans. Vielleicht können wir auch gleich mal mit dir einsteigen. Also du bist auch schon seit Ewigkeiten sozusagen im Computerkreis unterwegs. Ich weiß nicht, verdienst wahrscheinlich auch deinen Lebensunterhalt in irgendeiner Form damit. Zwangsläufig.
Kann ja nichts anderes.
Hat ja nichts anderes gelernt.
Ich habe mal einen ehrlichen Beruf gehabt, gell. Ich habe eine richtige Lehre gemacht als Elektriker.
Oha, aber war nicht so erfolgreich.
Nee, anschließend kam der Computer. 1976, 1977, 28.
Und dann kam die Computer bei dir?
Ja, ich habe genau zwei Monate nach der Ende meiner Lehre ehrlich gearbeitet und dann bin ich am ersten Computer gesessen.
Und?
Dienstlich.
Was war das für ein System?
Dienstlich, das war eine 370 Mainframe. Privat hatte ich zu dem Zeitpunkt schon mehrere Selbstbaucomputer und einen Apple. Klassischer Apple II. Unheimlich viel Lehrlingskohle für unheimlich viel wenig Rechner ausgegeben.
In heutigen Maßstäben gemessen.
3000 Mark für eine nackte Maschine, aber im Sonderangebot mit einem Kassettenrekorder dabei.
Immerhin.
War wirklich überteuert, aber ich habe null Ahnung gehabt. Am Anfang wirst du immer über den Tisch gezogen, hinterher sabberst du so lange, dass sie dich über den Tisch ziehen.
Hat dich aber trotzdem letzten Endes zu den Computern gebracht erfolgreich.
Ja, doch.
Und dann nehme ich mal an, bist du auch so diesen typischen Reiz erlegen, dem damals eigentlich alle so erlegen sind. Weltkontrollvorstellungen, Warnvorstellungen, Übernahme der Weltregierungen und so weiter?
Diese Weltregierungen, die können wir komplett ausschalten und direkt arbeiten. Das war nämlich gerade das Interessante dann auch zum Thema Kommunikation. Ich brauche keine Weltregierung mehr. Ich brauche niemand, der mir das sagt. Ich sage vielleicht aus dem Hintergrund den anderen, wie es langgeht.
Man muss sich mal diesen Überbau vorstellen und sich das Gewicht ausrechnen. Wenn man das weglässt, ist alles viel leichter.
Man muss nur nach Deutschland schauen, was wir alles an Überbau mittragen. Wenn wir die einsparen, könnten wir uns viel mehr Bankenbleiten leisten. Aber gut, das ist ein ganz anderes Thema.
Das Gewicht war damals viel geringer.
Aber ich glaube, wir werden hier noch häufig abschweifen in dieser Runde. Um noch mal kurz bei dir zu bleiben, also du bist halt zu den Rechnern gekommen, bist du damit auch gleich automatisch in so einen Benutzerkreis geraten, oder hast du dich dann erst mal allein in deinem Stellenkreis?
Nein, aber es war halt so, dass im Freundeskreis zu der Zeit eine ganze Reihe Leute auf Rechner gekommen sind. Irgendwie lag es in der Luft. Ich meine, Ende der 70er Jahre war die Zeit, wo man was mit Chips machen wollte, die viele Füße hatten oder mit so komischen Maschinen, die irgendwie was machen, was man nicht auf dem Knopfdruck alleine macht. Es war eine ganz heiße Zeit. Ich meine, meinen allerersten Computer habe ich mir selber zusammen gelötet, mit einem 70 Watt-Lötkolben. Als Elektriker war das der feinste, den ich hatte. Und 1 Quadrat Draht. Und drauf gekommen bin ich eigentlich nur, weil ich in der Zeitung eine Anzeige gesehen habe, dass der Chip 40 Füße hat. Und ich meine, als Lehrling im ersten Lehrjahr hast du ja gebastelt. Und je mehr Füße die Bauteile hatten, die du verbastelt hast, desto cooler warst du. Und 40 Füße war doch ultimativ.
Das war schon eine Menge, ja.
Also mit 70 Watt warst du kein Elektriker, sondern Kupferkessel-Monteur.
Ja, und irgendwann ist dann auch ganz schnell die Leitung dazu gekommen, sprich die ersten selbstgebauten Koppler und dann auch gekaufte Koppler.
Kostekoppler, wir reden von Datenkommunikation.
Natürlich Hochgeschwindigkeit, 300 Boot. Du hast schon fast nicht mehr mitlesen können. 1200 war ja schon unmenschlich und alles über 1200 kann nicht mehr sinnvoll sein.
Das ist dieses ganze neue Modus von heute.
Nein, 300 Boot war eigentlich sehr menschlich, weil man hat wirklich gut mitlesen können in der Geschwindigkeit. Es ist nicht zu langsam, nicht zu schnell gewesen. Man hat gut übertragen können. Und ich meine, die Handvoll Systeme, die man in Deutschland offiziell anwählen konnte oder halboffiziell, die hat man schnell abgehabt und dann ist man ganz schnell bei den ersten Paz der Deutschen Bundespost gelandet und hat sich überlegt, wie Datex B eigentlich funktioniert. Der Rest ist ganz normale Geschichte.
Ich meine, es hört sich ja so an, als ob damals Herrscharen von Leuten sich auf diese Technologie gestürzt haben. Dem war ja nicht so.
Nein, es haben sich Herrscharen drauf gestürzt. Herrscharen, von denen die Berührung mit der Technologie gekriegt haben. Das war natürlich absolut gesehen, wenn du die gesamte Bevölkerung nimmst, verschwindend gering, aber es waren schon sehr viele junge Leute, die Interesse gehabt haben, die irgendwie in Berührung gekommen sind und angefangen haben zu basteln, angefangen auszuprobieren, und sich wenigstens dafür interessiert haben. Viele sind genauso wie heute wieder abgesprungen. Es war natürlich auch so, dass du die Technik, die war einfach nicht so direkt zu verwenden wie heute. Du hast dir wirklich die Technik erarbeiten müssen. Damit hast du natürlich ein anderes Verhältnis gekriegt. Heute wirfst du das Ding an und noch bevor du das erste Fenster aufmachen kannst, ist so viel an Programm abgelaufen, was kein Mensch mehr bis zum Ende seiner Tage lesen kann. Damals war es so, du hast die Kiste eingeschaltet und es waren ungefähr 100 Assemblerbefehle, bevor es piep gemacht hat und die Meldung am Bildschirmstand in der Körse geblinkt hat. Das hat man verstanden.
Aber was man ja häufig findet, bei mir war es natürlich auch ähnlich in gewisser Hinsicht, ist halt so dieses, man beschäftigt sich mit so einer Technologie, insbesondere so mit Kommunikationstechnologie und man sieht halt die Möglichkeiten und man kann sich dann eben auch schnell aus seinem technischen Sachverstand heraus so ein paar Zukunftsszenarien bilden und dann fängt man natürlich an darüber nachzudenken. Das geht dann nicht selten einher mit so einem Gefühl, naja, wie soll man es sagen, dass man sich in so einer Schar von erleuchteten, außergewählten, so einer kleinen Elite bewegt, die jetzt sozusagen besonders visionär durch die Gegend schreit, weil sie irgendwie die Zukunft kommen sieht.
Das war eigentlich bei mir überhaupt nicht so. Bei mir war es mehr das Thema, das war ein wahnsinnig interessantes Wunderland. Und ich bin eigentlich nur unterwegs gewesen, um neue Ecken in dem Wunderland kennenzulernen. Und ich bin in jeder Ecke staunend rumgelaufen. Ich habe über die Wunder der Welt gestaunt, auch wenn sie elektrisch waren. Die Allmachtsfantasie hat sich gar nicht so richtig entwickelt, sondern ich habe hinter jeder Tür wieder was entdeckt und gar keine Zeit gehabt zu planen, wie ich den Rest, den ich schon entdeckt habe, beherrsche.
Okay, dann vielleicht noch mal kurz zu dem Treffen, was hier stattfindet. Was passiert hier?
Hier sind ungefähr 45 Aussteller. Die bringen jeweils eine oder mehrere alte und oder coole Maschinen mit und zeigen etwas Interessantes mit dieser Maschine, was da läuft, was die Maschine war. Das Ganze im Rahmen einer einigermaßen ansprechend aufgemachten Ausstellung. Die Idee ist, ein Museum für zwei Tage oder jetzt dieses Jahr sogar drei Tage. Das heißt, die Leute kommen zusammen aus der ganzen Republik, eigentlich aus ganz Europa, bringen ein Stückchen mit, zeigen, was war damals cool oder was tun sie jetzt noch damit Cooles. Und Besucher kommen und schauen sich das an. Es ist natürlich ganz klar, 80 Prozent der Besucher sind wiederum Technik-Fans. Aber richtig stolz bin ich auf die restlichen 20 Prozent. Ganz normale, ganz normale Bürger von der Straße rein, die wirklich mit Kinderwagen reinschieben und ihren Kindern erzählen, guck mal, Papi hat auch mal so ein C64 gehabt, wie das steht. Also es ist ein bisschen wie so diese üblichen User treffen, aber etwas mehr organisiert, damit es auch andere Leute reinholen, weil wir wollen das Hobby nach außen öffnen. Gleichzeitig ist es eine Basis, um möglichst vielen Leuten die Möglichkeit zu bieten, herzukommen. Also das VCF gehört keinem gewissen Club an, hängt an keinem Thema dran, als wir sind jetzt die Amiga-Leute oder wir sind die von dem Verein oder von jedem Verein, sondern offen für alle. Im Prinzip ist es eine Fortführung dessen, was die BHP zum Schluss war. Zum Ende hin haben wir nämlich versucht, also Ende hat es ja nicht gegeben, sondern zu den letzten veröffentlichten Ausgaben bis heute, haben wir versucht, die Zeitschrift zu öffnen und anderen Gruppen innerhalb der Zeitschrift die Möglichkeit zu geben, eigene ein, zwei Seiten zu gestalten. Also mehr eine Basis zu bieten, wo die Leute sagen können, okay, wir machen das hier, wir zeigen es euch jetzt und wir nehmen halt die Infrastruktur der BHP her, um unsere Idee zu vermitteln.
Du kannst auch so sehen, wir haben praktisches Alprinzip vorausgenommen, das jetzt heute in aller Munde ist. Andere arbeiten lassen, haben wir uns...
Rausschneiden, rausschneiden.
Aber bleiben wir noch mal einen Moment noch in den Zeiten davor. Also zum VCF muss ja, als ich als ich hier reinkam, ich hatte auch gleich so einen privaten Flashback, weil ich kam mir vor, wie auf so einer, wie hieß denn noch die Veranstaltung damals? Hieß die Hobbitronic irgendwie, das auch so frühe Computermessen war und so. Da standen also damals, als ich da in, ich glaube in Dortmund war das, in der Messehalle, da standen dann auch so ziemlich genau die gleichen Rechner, aber noch als brandneue Maschinen rum. Das war so der ganze heiße Scheiß. Und ja, jetzt, was haben wir, 25 Jahre später, naja, ist das natürlich insofern interessant. Das wollte ich jetzt noch mal kurz aufgreifen, was du meinst. So dieses, klar, natürlich könnte man so schnell so diesen Vorwurf ableiten, naja, da sitzen jetzt die alten Säcke und so weiter und trauern den alten Zeiten nach. Das mag zum gewissen Teil auch so sein. Fühl ich mich gelosen.
Ich finde es total scheiße, dass ich kein Tippix mehr benutzen darf.
Ja, aber der Punkt ist, es ist halt diese Nachvollziehbarkeit der Technologie. Also, während man heute wirklich komplexe Chips in dem Sinne gar nicht mehr erfassen kann, gut, mit den Chips war das natürlich auch damals schon schwierig, aber der gesamte diskrete Aufbau der Maschinen hat einen einen ganz anderen Zugang, ein ganz anderes Verständnis des Gesamtsystems erlaubt, was heute so ohne Weiteres nicht zu machen ist. Von so wem finde ich das halt auch nach wie vor interessant und würde es auch immer.
Darf ich da was Philosophisches einwerfen? Immer. Es ist ja auch der Punkt. Schau dir die Computerverbildung der Bevölkerung an, der Computerbevölkerung. Es wird geblinkt und verbundet und alles so schön bunt hier in Niederhagen mäßig. In Wirklichkeit blickt ja keiner mehr überhaupt durch. Und was damals einfach der Unterschied war und was man diesen relativ einfach gestrickten Maschinen auch noch nachvollziehen kann, lernen kann, ist der grundsätzliche strukturelle Aufbau von dieser ganzen Welt, die uns heute umgibt, die damals überhaupt noch niemand für möglich gehalten hat. Und ohne Kenntnis von diesem strukturellen Aufbau oder ich sage mal Fingerspitzengefühl dafür, ist man dieser Medium-Tampel hilflos ausgeliefert. Deswegen hat es durchaus auch Sinn, sich einfach mit diesen Technologien auseinanderzusetzen. Weil wie schaut es denn aus? Man kauft sich ein Notebook, starten, funktioniert, ah ja, geh mal in die Chatten rum und alles so schön bunt hier und keine Ahnung, wie geht. Man weiß eigentlich nicht, was da läuft. Aber es ist ja alles faktal aus ganz einfachen Grundstrukturen aufgebaut, sehr komplex zwar. Und wer die ganz einfachen Grundprinzipien nicht kennt, der steht sein Leben lang im Wald.
Kommen wir doch mal gleich auch zu dir, Thomas. Was ist so dein Einstieg in die Computerwelt gewesen? Oder bist du nur so ein Mitläufer?
Ich bin nur ein Mitläufer. Also bei mir, ich habe nicht Elektriker gelernt, sondern habe Kommunikationswissenschaften studiert. Ich bin gelernter Redakteur, also Zeitungs-Mensch, Medien-Mensch. Und ich habe mich irgendwann maßlos, nachdem ich meine fünfte Schreibmaschine, also zuerst habe ich angefangen mit einer ganz einfachen, so in einem Lederkoffer drin, da hat die Mechanik nicht funktioniert. Irgendwann kamen dann diese ganz tollen elektrischen Schreibmaschinen mit Kugelkopf, da konnte man mit Tipp-Ex arbeiten, irgendwann hat das mich geärgert. Dann kamen die Magnetspeicher, Schreibautomaten oder Textomaten, hießen die damals, da hat noch keiner Computer gesetzt, schon mit Menüsteuerung. Und ich bin eigentlich über das Schreiben dazu gekommen, zunehmend, weil mich einfach Kommunikation interessiert. Und mediale Aufbereitung, Nutzung von Medien, ob das jetzt Papieres oder Computer, das ist aus meiner Sicht relativ egal. Ich finde Computer wesentlich interessanter als Papier. Das war mein Einstieg. Und da bin ich gleichzeitig übrigens in Hamburg und in München fast parallel mit verschiedenen Leuten zusammen gestoßen, die damit arbeiten. Und habe mich von Anfang an, das sind mittlerweile einfach fast 25 Jahre, mit dieser Mediennutzung befasst. Also hier entsteht ein Medium. Dieses Medium wird Formen entwickeln, wird Strukturen entwickeln. Wie geht man damit um? Was von den unbegrenzten technischen Möglichkeiten ist sinnvoll einsetzbar? Was lässt man lieber bleiben, weil es Blödsinn ist? Das ist das, was mich interessiert und von Anfang an interessiert hat.
Das ist ja auch ein wiederkehrendes Mem. In der Computerlandschaft hat man das beileibe nicht nur, also gerade in dieser Hacker-Szene hat man es beileibe nicht nur mit Leuten, die sich ausschließlich mit der Technik beschäftigen zu tun, sondern auch im CCC. Wenn man sich da halt umschaut, gibt es eine ganz breit gestreute Partizipation aus allen Teilen der Gesellschaft. Also Leuten, die das kommunikative Element, medienteil, wie du das jetzt sagst, interessiert, aber auch Juristen, die sich mit ganz anderen konkreten gesellschaftlichen Implikationen dann auch interessieren und auch das logische Spiel schätzen und viele andere Sachen mehr.
Ja, mein Einstieg war eben die Mediennutzung. Ich habe mich auch während meinem Studium von Kommunikationswissenschaften schon zu einer Zeit damit beschäftigt und sehr intensiv damit beschäftigt. Da waren die halt auf der Uni noch nicht so weit.
Kommunikationswissenschaften, wann hast du das studiert?
Wann war das? 82, 81, 80.
War das da noch ein neuer Studiengang?
Nein, da war das überhaupt noch kein Studiengang. Da war das im Prinzip noch Zeitungswissenschaft, Publizistik. Okay, verstehe. Aber ich habe halt einfach dieses neue Medium da auf dem ansehen. Insofern sind also auch bei mir keine Weltregierungsgedanken aufgekommen, sondern...
Ich sehe schon, mir mislingt hier eine ordentliche Verschwörungssendung.
Gib uns zehn Sekunden. Haben wir zehn, haben wir sofort. Was mich interessiert hat, war das neue Medien und die Mitarbeit an einer neuen Medienlandschaft. So kann man das, glaube ich, am klarsten sagen.
Ja, dann kommen wir vielleicht noch mal hier zu dem dritten an die so richtig vorgestellten Teilnehmer. Norbert, bis denn bei dir?
Ja, bei mir ist es ganz anders. Ich kam eigentlich über die Musik zum Computer.
Ich mache auch Musik, gell?
Ja, ich habe es gelesen im Netz. Dulzima, meine Frau spielt auch Dulzima.
Ich baue sie.
Sehr gut. Dulzima?
Ja, das ist eine Produnziter. Wunderschön.
Da schweifen wir jetzt vielleicht etwas ab.
Das ist Kohletechnik.
Das ist richtig Retro, ne? Achthund Jahre zurück.
Genau, also nicht ganz so schlimm, aber ich bin eigentlich zur Elektronik gekommen, weil ich immer dachte, ich kann nur Klavier spielen, das ist ein bisschen Fahrt, baue dir mal einen Synthesizer und sowas. Damals gab es so kleine Handbücher zum Serverbau von Synthesizern. Irgendwann bin ich in Richtung Digitalelektronik gelandet, logischerweise analog-digital. Und wenn man sich mit dem digitalen Zeug richtig gut auskennt, landet man irgendwann beim Computer. Und da ich mir damals auch naturgemäß keinen Computer kaufen konnte, weil das war ja unerschwinglicher, wenn überhaupt nicht möglich, bin ich auch dran gegangen, das Ding selber zu bauen. Und so ging es halt über die CPM-Rechner in Richtung Apple II, über alle möglichen Single-Board-Computer, ZX81 und so weiter. Ging es irgendwann in Richtung größere Rechner. Und da die mich immer interessiert haben und ich nicht richtig an die Range gekommen bin, habe ich mir gedacht, es gibt doch große Rechner, die einen dazu einladen, sie zu nutzen, die auch offen sind, also ganz legal nutzbar sind. Und so kam er dann irgendwann zum Selbstbau von so einem Modem, von so einem Akustikkoppler, was sagt man, einem Datenklo. Ich glaube, das kommt sogar von euch der Ausdruck. Weil wir in der Sanitäterabteilung irgendwo beim Baumarkt mussten wir diese Gummimuffen kaufen, wo dann der Hörer reinklemmt. Und die 300 Boards haben wir genossen. Und es war natürlich damals, und genau das habt ihr auch angesprochen, es war wahnsinnig schwer eigentlich überhaupt mal eine Community aufzubauen. Weil man hatte nicht die Möglichkeit eines Jets, einer von E-Mail, sondern man musste erstmal seine Leute suchen. Ich habe Elektrotechnik studiert. Mein Vater sagte immer, die Lampe ist kaputt. Du hast sie studiert, schraub sie rein.
Und warum geht es nicht? Weil du keine zwei indischen Ingenieure zum Helfen hast, die dich drehen.
Doch, die Hand ist noch fähig. Nein, nein, ich kam auch über eben genau diese Geschichte, das Interesse zu forschen, weiterzumachen, das Interesse eigentlich, Kommunikation zu erleben. Da war nichts irgendwie Böses dahinter, da war auch nichts zu Versives dahinter. Ich wollte auch nicht politisch was umwerfen oder bewegen, sondern es war einfach interessant, Computer zu vernetzen. Und das konnte man nicht besser, als wie mit den Modems damals. Und man hat dann Kontakte gesucht. In der Uni waren Kontakte relativ schnell aufzutreiben. Und dann hat sich dieser Kreis relativ schnell, ich muss mal sagen erweitert. Und so sind wir dann auch in Richtung Axel usw. gekommen und haben uns immer öfter getroffen und dachten, das, was wir ein bisschen bearbeiten und sammeln, das sollte man eigentlich mal kommunizieren. Und so kamen wir zur Bayerischen Hackerpost.
Ja, jetzt müssen wir es auch nochmal erwähnen. Es gibt ja leider einen Schatten, der auf diesem Wochenende liegt. Insofern, als dass wir eigentlich hier auch gedacht haben, den Axel Grießmann mit dabei zu haben, der ganz wesentlich Teil des BHP-Projektes war, oder ich weiß nicht, wie ihr es darstellen würdet, schon eine sehr zentrale Rolle mit aufgenommen hat. Leider ist Axel vor einer Woche ums Leben gekommen, bei einem Motorradunfall, wo wir natürlich auch noch einen Moment darüber nachgedacht haben, ob wir jetzt hier überhaupt so ohne Weiteres diesen Blick zurück wagen können. Ich finde es trotzdem gut, dass das jetzt geklappt hat. Du bist dann sozusagen mit Axel irgendwann mal zusammengeraten oder kanntet ihr euch schon?
Ja, wir sind zusammengeraten über Mailboxen, haben uns irgendwie kennengelernt. Es war erstmal ganz witzig, dass es in München offensichtlich so einen kleinen Kreis von lebensbejahenden DFÜ-Benutzern, Datenfernübertragungsbenutzern, gab. Und so sind wir von der Elektrotechnik-Uni-Seite, wir waren damals zu dritt, in Richtung dieser Gruppe in München gegangen. Und so hat sich also eigentlich so richtig schön, wie war es im Terminator, wenn sich dieses flüssige Metall so sieht.
Guter Vergleich.
So war es hier bei uns.
Ja, ein klassisches Prinzip der Selbstorganisation.
Ja, genau, richtig. Aber wie gesagt, ohne Internet.
Das haben wir auch beibehalten, ne?
Ja, das ging dann weiter eben. Und dann haben wir uns überlegt, wie soll so ein Ding ausschauen. Wir brauchten ein bisschen erstmal ein witziges Layout. Wir haben uns natürlich auch mit CCC in Verbindung gesetzt. Also sind wir erst mal hochgefahren zu euch in der Anfangszeit.
Das habt ihr schon wahrgenommen. Ich kann mich auch noch erinnern, in der Zeit war es ja nun nicht so ohne Weiteres. Es gab kein Web, es gab halt wenig Netze, es gab nur die Mailboxen, aber die waren ja auch sehr regional in der Regel. Wie kamen ihr überhaupt in Kontakt mit anderen Städten?
Moment, da muss man jetzt mal eins sagen.
Ja, sag mal eins.
Wir sind hier in Bayern. Bayern hat schon immer ein Auge auf die Welt. Man muss schauen, was in unterentwickelten Gebieten passiert. Und das heißt natürlich, dass wir vielleicht, verglichen mit anderen Regionen der Welt, überdurchschnittlich gut informiert sind.
Verstehe, also das ist nicht mehr so eine überregionale Tätigkeit als mehr so das Außenministerium.
Nein, es ist ganz einfach. Wenn man was machen will, dann sollte man nie ignorieren, was andere machen. Ignorieren, was andere machen, ist die erste und letzte Dummheit, die man macht. Und wir versuchen eigentlich nicht dumm zu sein.
Und nachmachen, ohne versuchen, es besser zu machen, ist auch blöd.
Aber wie seid ihr erst mal in Kenntnis gekommen?
Der Hauptdaten-Austausch erfolgt erst mal über die Mailboxen.
Und traditionell bayerische Überstammtische.
Ja, genau, die wirklich treffen, sich einfach regelmäßig in bestimmten Wirtshäusern treffen.
Aber kennengelernt habt ihr euch über Mailboxen. Was gab es für eine Mailboxen damals?
Die waren zum Teil privat organisiert. Fast eigentlich alle.
Ja, es gab auch noch ein paar Verzeichnisse, die man auf Rechnern als Mailboxen verwendet hat. Das war mehr stille Briefkästen, das Mailboxen. Also nicht so, wie man es heute kennt.
Weil man nur einer anrufen kann gleichzeitig.
Dann parallel dazu liefen im Datex-P-Bereich die ersten privaten Boxen wie eben Geonet, Combox und so weiter. Da ist auch viel drüber gelaufen.
Das war dann schon die Weiterentwicklung.
Das war dann die Schnittstelle zu den...
Aber es gab jetzt nicht so eine Heim-Mailbox hier in München, wo irgendwie alle aufschlugen?
Wir sind, glaube ich, genetisch dezentral programmiert.
Deswegen funktioniert das auch mit der Wendrik hier auch nicht.
In Hamburg zu dem Zeitpunkt gab es zum Beispiel MCSHH, die schon eine einigende Wirkung hatte.
Es gab bei uns im Umfeld immer so viel. Aber nachdem wir uns nie wirklich einig werden können...
Ja, wir setzen auch die Elemente ein, die klassische vieler toleranten Rechensysteme einsetzen. Diversität und Redundanz.
Insofern ist das Internet sozusagen auch ein Abbild dessen, was die Bayerische Hackerpost war.
Sagen wir mal ganz ehrlich, das klingt jetzt unheimlich gut.
Ich will auch jetzt das Image, was wir gerade vermitteln, nicht kaputt machen.
Letztendlich war es so, es gab verschiedene Mailboxen. Es ist nicht so gewesen, dass es diesen einen Punkt gegeben hat. Und es gab da zwischen die erwähnten Stammtische und Treffen. Und A und B hängen in einer Mailbox rum, C und D in der anderen. Aber C und B zusammen gehen auf den selben Stammtisch. Und D geht wieder mit F auf den Stammtisch. Und schon bildet sich eine Kommunikationskette. Und Wissen verbreitet sich. Ich meine, man kann das Ganze, was ich vorhin gesagt habe, auch umgekehrt sehen. Fahrt mal irgendwo nach Afrika. Ihr findet im tiefsten Dschungel, findet ihr FC Bayern-Fanclubs. Nein, ohne Schmarrn.
Ja, ich weiß.
Ich habe das erlebt. Ich habe erlebt, dass ich in Indien war. Und in Indien hinter Karl Kutter, wirklich im absoluten Dschungel, will einer mit mir über das Spiel vom FC Bayern von der letzten Woche reden. Das war irgendwas Champions Club oder sowas. Also ich habe gedacht, ich stirb. Information ist schon immer, auch vor vielen Jahrhunderten, rasend schnell um die Welt gewandert. Es gibt keine geschlossenen Sachen und die anderen wissen das nicht. Es ist alles Kommunikation. Und das geht auch ohne irgendeinen zentralen Hub. Und genauso ist eigentlich hier in Bayern die Szene entstanden.
Man redet miteinander. Und es findet einfach auf verschiedenen Kommunikationsebenen statt. Es war eben keine zentrale Mailbox da in dem Sinne, sondern es gab eben sofort mehrere. Die waren aber letztlich auch wieder nur Ausdruck aus einem formlosen Kommunikationsumfeld, was einfach gewachsen ist, ausgehuchert ist, Blüten geschlagen hat.
Und irgendwann gab es den Wunsch doch mal, auch eine Zeitung zu machen. Wer hatte denn die Idee?
Axel.
Das war Axel, ja, eindeutig.
Aber du warst von Anfang an dabei, oder?
Ja, ich war mit den ersten Ausgaben dabei, bis circa Nummer 5 oder so was.
Und was hast du zu der Idee gemeint, als du das erste Mal auf dem Tisch lag? Ich fand es gut.
Weil wir hatten eine Menge Daten gesammelt oder Erfahrungen gesammelt, die wir irgendwie so weitergeben konnten. Es gab kein www.
Das heißt, eigentlich habt ihr eine Webseite aufgebaut, bloß da es noch keine gab.
Genau, deswegen mussten wir uns ja das Web erfinden.
Das war unser Webwert mehr oder weniger. Das ist jetzt rausgekommen dabei. Und jetzt nach 25 Jahren ist natürlich hier auch das Bedürfnis da, das Ganze wieder mal zu beleuchten und ein bisschen darüber nachzudenken.
25 Jahre. Die erste Ausgabe erschien wann? Die zweite ist hier Februar 85. Ich habe die Einzige gerade nicht in der Hand.
Im November 81.
84 müsste es gewesen sein.
Ja, 85 war es. Die zweite kam 85. Die erste müsste knapp 84, 85 sein.
81 sind nur noch Textautomaten, das weiß ich noch.
Also das heißt, die Bayerische Hackerpost erschien sozusagen kurz nachdem der CCC auch 84 mit der Datenschleuder angefangen hat. Das heißt, die Datenschleuder war sozusagen auch schon, war euch die schon bekannt?
Die war bekannt, ja.
Es gab auch schon eine Handvoll Ausgaben Datenschleuder, glaube ich.
Ja, aber ihr wart schneller als wir. Das weiß ich noch.
Und dann?
Wahrscheinlich weniger Bier da oben.
Das heißt, es war auch schon so ein bisschen Rollmodel, so ein bisschen. Sowas müssen wir auch machen. Ich meine, das wäre natürlich naheliegend. Hackerpost, muss man sagen, ist halt jetzt keine große Zeitung, sondern halt so den A5-Heftchen, wie man das damals hat, einfach produzieren können. Immerhin gab es ja schon so Copyshops, mit denen man so die Vervielfältigung halbwegs günstig machen konnte. Und dann muss ich das ja auch mal vorstellen. Also die Produktionsmethoden, ich weiß nicht, wo im Moment habt ihr das, also wenn ich mir, sah die 1 genauso aus wie die 2? Ich habe die 1 jetzt gerade nicht vor der Nase, aber das sieht mir jetzt mal nach einem Epson FX80 Drucker aus, so auf den ersten Blick. Habe ich das so?
Ziemlich genauer Treffer. Ich weiß nicht, ob es ein FX war.
Ich würde sagen, das war ein FX. Nein, das ist ein FX80, das sehe ich ja in der Kleinschrift.
Auf jeden Fall. Drucken.
Diese eine Nadel ist verbogen.
Auf Apple II. Dann Drucken, ausschneiden, kleben. Ganz wichtig war das Sammeln von interessanten und passenden Überschriften und Einklebern aus anderen Zeitschriften, Zeitungen und sonst was. Weil wir hatten ja nur eine Schriftart, die normale Schrift. Und dann gab es noch die gespreizte, die wir hier bei der Ausgabe 2 zum Beispiel fürs Datum genommen haben. Ansonsten alles andere, was man in Überschriften und großen Texten liest, sind aus Zeitungen, Zeitschriften zusammengeklaut und zusammengeklebt.
Also hier steht die bayerische Hackerpost, das Informationsblatt für den lebensbejahenden DFÜ-Benutzer. Warum die Unterschrift? Es ist... Positiv denken.
Ja, auch wenn man sich die Datenschleuder hernimmt. Wir haben ja gerade gesagt, die Datenschleuder war eine Idee näher oder eine Idee älter. Es ging auch ein bisschen um Differenzierung.
Im Gegensatz zur Datenschleuder kam ja mit dem Untertitel wissenschaftliches... also hier steht Fachblatt für Datenreisende. Genau.
Und bei uns ging es von Anfang an darum, dass wir gesagt haben, das ist nicht bierernst. Ja, Bier ist zwar eine ernste Sache, aber DFÜ nicht.
Preise Deutschland zwei Mark, Schweiz zwei Schweizer Franken 50, USA zwei TAPs. Das bezieht sich auf das entsprechende Magazin aus den USA. Die TAP, die ja eigentlich auch ein bisschen Vorbild wiederum auch für die Datenschleuder gewesen ist. Aus Taiwan hat man sich eine Apple-Karte gewünscht. Aus den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten zwei Galonen. Sprit nehme ich mal an.
Ja, natürlich.
Singapur soll 1 kg ICs liefern und die UDSSR eine 80, 80 Kopie. Das sind die Preise der bayerischen Hackerpost gewesen.
Die über die ganze Laufzeit übrigens stabil waren, zumindest die deutschen Preise. Wie man weiß, ist die Marke immer kräftiger geworden. Deswegen sind auch die Auslandspreise geändert worden. Zum Beispiel musste die UDSR irgendwann mal eine 80, 86 Kopie liefern.
Das heißt, der Inhalt war schon technisch weiterhelfend. Es ging um die Kommunikation als solche. Weniger jetzt erst mal die politische Note, wie sie ja beim Club immer stärker im Vordergrund hing. Trotzdem, Hackerpost bezieht sich ja auch nun explizit auf den Begriff. Was habt ihr euch mit dem Begriff Hacker verbunden?
Also wir haben hier eine Brauerei.
Man darf nicht vergessen, dass wir oben zu unserem Stammtisch immer bei der Hackerbrücke aussteigen mussten. Um sich so etwas besser merken zu können. So etwas ist ja auch ein Ansatz. Hacker ist tief verwurzelt mit München. Und wenn Sie in München fragen, dann kommt der Hacker niemals auf Hacker.
Sondern immer auf Hackerpschor.
Hackerpschor kommt später. Aber die Hackerbrücke gibt es schon wirklich lange. Die hat einfach Tradition.
Hacker bezieht sich dann auf was?
Auf die Brauerei. Hacker und Pschor sind zwei Brauereien. Das ist eine frühe, unfreundliche Übernahme gewesen, die manche Münchner immer noch nicht vergnust haben. Ist noch keine 100 Jahre her. Das ist noch frisch im Gedächtnis.
Oder wolltest du hier irgendwie auf War Games raus?
Hat ja jeder seinen eigenen Ansatz.
Wir haben hier einen bayerischen speziellen Denkansatz.
Wo ist denn die Hacker postproduziert worden?
Oh, das war ein komplizierter Vorgang. Die ersten Ausgaben. Die Leute haben die Texte angeliefert zu Axel. Bei den ersten drei Heften hat Axel die Schlussredaktion gemacht.
Die haben überwacht zu hoffen, oder?
Nein, Penningparade. Penningparade ist eine Wohnanlage für...
Ist noch Max Vorstadt, genau.
Für Behinderte. Und da hat Axel Zivildienst gehabt. Und hat dort gewohnt. Und hat ein winzig kleines Kapuff gehabt, was wirklich nur aus seinem Bett war. Jeder Menge Regalen mit jeder Menge Software. Und Hardware. Das Zimmer war aufgeräumt eigentlich. Aber es war das Musterbild, wie man sich eine Hackerhöhle vorstellt. Weil das Licht war auch sehr klein, das Fenster. Und wenn man auf die Nummer 2 der BHP schaut, dann ist da ein Bild, wie der Hund in seinem Zimmer sitzt und am Computer sitzt. Das ist eigentlich eine Reminiszenz an Axel in seiner Bude.
Dieser Hund ist ja so ein bisschen wiederkehrendes Logo, kann man vielleicht nicht sagen. Ein Maskottchen der BHP, immer gewesen. Was hat das mit diesem Hund auf sich?
Nein, da sagst du am besten was dazu. Mein Gedächtnis ist, dass der Hundezeichner wiederum ein Freund von Axel war. Der hat schon zu Schulzeiten diesen Hund gezeichnet. Das war irgendwie so sein Dudel, wenn er rumgesessen ist und nicht wusste, was er tun soll. Das heißt, der Lehrer ihn genervt hat, hat er Hunde gezeichnet. Dabei ist diese Figur entstanden. Beim Entstehen der Hackerpost war der Hund verfügbar als Zeichnung. Also hat man hergenommen. Er wurde dann wirklich unser Logo, unser Symbol.
Wir hatten noch einen Mitbegründer damals, den Florian, und den sein Freund war eben dieser Zeichner. Und der war auch öfters dabei. Das war auch ein begeisterter Computerspieler, ein Computerfan. Wir haben irgendwann den Hund von ihm gesehen. Oder er hatten irgendwann, glaube ich, Buttermelcher Hof hat das aus Kitschen gemacht. Ich erinnere mich. Und dann kamen wir drauf, Mensch, diesen Hund können wir doch nehmen. Der wäre doch klasse. Und das war die Motivation für dieses Symbol, möchte ich mal sagen, für die BHP.
Dazu gibt es dann auch eine Weiterentwicklung des Hundes. Die ist aber offiziell vom Bayerischen Rundfunk nicht bestätigt. Und wird auch vehement abgestritten. Das hat gädelige Gründe. Es ist so, dass Stefan, Stefan war damals unser C64-Pastler, der hatte zu dem Zeitpunkt, 87 rum muss das gewesen sein, eine Arbeit beim Bayerischen Rundfunk, wo es darum ging, für eine Quiz-Show mit einem Amiga die Bildschirmsteuerung zu machen. Das hat er programmiert. Unter anderem hat er verschiedene Leute, die auch für die Produktion der Sendung Formel 1 zuständig waren.
Das war diese Musik-Show?
Diese Musik-Show, wo man heute wirklich grinst, wenn man sie sieht. Insgesamt, wenn man über die Musik grinst, hat er auch die BHPs gezeigt und auch über den Hund schwadroniert.
Im Fernsehen?
Nein, mit den Leuten, mit den Machern. Es war ungefähr drei Monate später, vier Monate später, wo dann komischerweise zum ersten Mal dieses neue Maskottchen, der Formel 1 aufgetaucht ist, so ein gezeichneter Hund, der recht frech durch die Gegend hopft. Also der Bayerische Rundfunk behauptet, es gäbe keinen Zusammenhang. Ich würde jetzt sagen, ich konstruiere keinen.
Dabei ist das ganz klein, unähliges Kind.
Hat der den Namen, der Hund? Nein, hat keinen.
Doch, der heißt Hund.
Ist denn jetzt sozusagen die politische Dimension dessen, hinter der Gründung des Clubs und später eben auch Datenschleuder und Kongress, was ja auch alles 1984 losgegangen ist, stand ja schon auch so ein bisschen die Erkenntnis, dass die Computer diese Gesellschaft halt auch beeinflussen werden.
Nein, halt.
Du widersprichst?
Die Benutzer der Computer?
Richtig, die Menschen beeinflussen die Gesellschaft. Aber mit dem Computer ist natürlich ein neues Werkzeug reingekommen, mit dem eine Möglichkeit bestand, an der Gesellschaft auch ein bisschen rumzuschrauben, sage ich mal so.
Und war das nicht dann auch sozusagen, also spielt das bei euch auch eine Rolle?
Ja, und zwar insofern, und das ist ja auch dasselbe wie mit dem Titel, als dass wir eine sehr, sehr liberale Einstellung haben. Und zwar jetzt nicht liberal im Sinne bestimmter Parteien, die sich so nennen, sondern liberal im Sinne von Freiheit. Ja, ich meine, da schlägt vielleicht das bayerische Wesen, die unbedingt die Freiheitswillen in Bayern durch. Wir lassen uns von Nermans was sagen. Und also wir lassen uns von niemandem etwas vorschreiben.
Ich muss jetzt Untertitel machen.
Bitte hören Sie 10 cm tiefer. Nein. Es ist so, neue Techniken bringen neue Freiheiten, nicht neue Beschränkungen. Und für uns war immer ganz wichtig, dass diese Freiheiten ausgelebt werden können. Und bitte, Beschränkungen brauche ich niemand, der mir vorschreibt. Ich merke es schon selber, wenn es nicht passt. Beziehungsweise die Leute merken es selber. Ich brauche niemanden, der mir etwas verbietet. Ich brauche vielleicht jemanden, der mich ermutigt.
Und wenn ich da gleich mal so richtig in die Medientheorie gehen darf, wir haben ja eine Medienlandschaft vorgefunden damals, die davon geprägt war, dass Öffentlichkeit oder öffentliche Meinung nur erzeugt werden könnte, konnte mit von Leuten, die über sehr große Kapitalmassen an Produktionsmitteln verfügten. Also ich muss einen Verlag haben, um eine Zeitung zu drucken. Um sie unter das Volk zu bringen, brauche ich einen Vertrieb. Um sie ins Bewusstsein rücken, brauche ich Marketing. Computer ist jetzt ein Medium, wo ich fast keinen Produktionsmitteleinsatz brauche. Und damit ist das natürlich in die Radiotherapie von Bert Brecht praktisch hineingewachsen.
Auch in Bayer, gell?
Streit muss ich noch, das ist ein Schwaben.
Also Brechts Radiotherapie, kurz zusammengefasst, diese Vision, jeder ist ein Sender, jeder kann selber...
Einfach durch die Computertechnologie ist der Aufwand an Produktionsmittel, um Informationen zu verbreiten, radikal gesunken und mittlerweile praktisch auf Null. Das gibt eine völlig neue Situation.
Hat sich das positiv ausgewirkt jetzt über diese ganze Zeit?
Da könnte man vielleicht den George Bush dazu fragen oder den Obama, weil das wirkt sich weltweit aus. Ganz klar, das liegt jetzt nicht an der Bayerischen Hacker-Post.
Jetzt sind es 25 Jahre BHP sozusagen, also jetzt nicht auf den Tag genau, aber 1984, sagen wir mal, ging es los.
Also wir sind nicht schuld, dass der George Bush gewählt worden ist.
Nee, das wollte ich euch jetzt auch nicht unterstellen.
Wir sind auch nicht schuld.
Inwiefern sind eure Erwartungen oder Hoffnungen damals, was jetzt Kommunikation ermöglichen kann, erfüllt oder nicht erfüllt worden? Also wenn ihr euch jetzt anschaut, was jetzt in diesen 25 Jahren passiert ist, hat das im Wesentlichen dem entsprochen und eure Erwartungen auch erfüllt, was sich damals abgezeichnet hat? Oder ist das jetzt auch mit einer gewissen Enttäuschung oder Ernüchterung verbunden?
Ich sag mal, so muss halt, wenn man Kinder auf die Welt bringt, dann braucht es halt Zeit. Und wenn ich mir jetzt zum Beispiel bloß so das Internet anschaue, ja gut, jetzt kann ich halt die Babysocken schon mal selber ausziehen, bis ich die Kinderschuhe allein zumachen kann. Das dauert noch ein bisschen, das dauert einfach. Also das ist für Erfolg oder Misserfolg ist noch viel zu früh. Und außerdem wird sich das einfach entwickeln.
Also ich meine jetzt mal als Zwischenbilanz, was würdest du denn sagen, sind denn, also gibt es irgendwie, ist das jetzt alles, ist es jetzt gerade so in der Teenager-Phase und man hat das Gefühl, eigentlich geht alles gerade in eine ganz andere Richtung, die man so nicht wollte, aber das wird schon. Oder siehst du schon auch gewisse Erfolge auf dem Weg dahin?
Das sind ja nicht meine Erfolge oder unsere.
Naja, also aber jetzt mal aus deinem persönlichen Kanal, weil du hast ja auch gesagt, Medientheorie, Kommunikation, das hat dich interessiert. Es geht ja nicht darum, ein Medien zu entwerfen.
Ein Medium findet seine Form letztlich selber. Das kann niemand entwerfen. Bis jetzt ist noch jeder Versuch, also auch beim Fernsehen und beim Radio schiefgelaufen, zu versuchen, einem Medium eine bestimmte Form überzustülpen. Das Medium wird sich seine Form immer selber suchen. Das heißt, man kann dem Medium helfen, mit praktisch seine Möglichkeiten zu entdecken, mit diesen Möglichkeiten zu spielen, neue Möglichkeiten auszureizen. Und so ist eigentlich beim Medium Computer und Internet genauso.
Du wirst ja gewisse Erwartungen daran geknüpft haben, was jetzt hinter dieser Bränche in keinen Auffall gemacht wird.
Jetzt kann sich gerade die Bibelssocken alleine ausziehen.
Das heißt, du bist der Meinung, das wird schon. Das ist eigentlich alles super.
Es wird wachsen, in welche Richtung wird man sehen. Und wenn man keinen Scheiß baut, dann nennt man das eine gute Erziehung.
Na gut, aber wenn es jetzt nur daran geht, nach Partizipation, also Partizipationsmöglichkeiten. Wir hatten ja gesagt, 25 Jahre, jetzt wollen wir mal eine Zeitung oder jetzt wollen wir mal Informationen in die Welt setzen. Was machen wir? Dann bedrucken wir irgendwie ein paar Papierflyer und streuen die durch die Gegend. Heute kann man natürlich ganz anders publizieren. Da macht man sich irgendwie seinen Blog auf. Würdest du sagen, dass das schon eine, dass es ein qualitativer Zugewinn ist an Signifikanta?
Oder ist das schon wie... Ja, also wenn man eine E-Zelle befruchtet, so als Männchen, also wir sind ja hier nur ein Männchen am Tisch, dann fängt das ja auch erstmal mit Zwei an und da sieht man doch nicht viel.
Na gut, aber 25 Jahre ist ja nun schon...
Die Lebensdauer auf dem Internet ist, glaube ich, nicht direkt gekopiert.
Du willst sie nicht festlegen, okay.
Nein, nein, wenn ich da mal reinspringen darf.
Das ist ein Prozess.
Ich sehe es eigentlich, das, was ich mir erwartet habe damals, sehe ich heute gegeben.
Was hast du dir erwartet?
Ich habe nur zurückgeschaut und habe geschaut, was ist mit dem Buchdruck passiert. Klar, Gutenberg hat eine Bibel geschrieben bzw.
gedruckt.
Aber direkt anschließend sind jede Menge schlimmster pseudowissenschaftlicher Scheiße gedruckt worden.
Hexenhammer.
Also ich hoffe, das Wort darf drin bleiben.
Hexenhammer war eine Folge der Druckkunst, also nicht nur die Luttabil. Der Hexenhammer. Der Hexenhammer war praktisch im Mittelalter, oder im ausgehenden Mittelalter, das Pseudolehrbuch für Hexenverfolgung. Das wurde auch über die Druckkunst verbreitet, die der Gutenberg aufgebracht hat, die letztlich mit der Lutte-Übersetzung...
Die Hexenschleuder sozusagen.
Das war der Hexenhammer. Da stand hammerartig drin, wie man Hexen erkennt, wie man sie fertig machen muss. Und wie man verhörte, ein völlig geisteskrankes Konstrukt.
Wenn ein Medium, ein breiter Bevölkerung...
Von einem Tiroler Pfarrer, das war kein Ball.
Dann wird es auch genutzt. Ich glaube, es war ein Paradigmenwechsel. In der Zeit, als wir die BHP geschrieben haben, war die Nutzung der Computer fast nur den im Vorbehalten, die auch computer-a programmieren konnten bzw. sie verstanden. Wie ganz früher die Rennfahrer, die ersten, konnten ihre Motoren selbst reparieren.
Du musstest in die Technik erarbeiten.
So ist es.
Das haben wir im Automobilbereich, das haben wir in vielen anderen technischen Bereichen. Hier ist es genauso. Wir haben darauf hinwirken wollen, verstehe, was du nutzt. Verstehe möglichst viel, was du nutzt. Dann ist auch sicher, was du nutzt. Das hat sich ja komplett geändert. Da bin ich etwas enttäuscht, weil ich habe damals immer erwartet, wenn ich mal Kinder habe, dann wird er den Computer perfekt verstehen und perfekt nutzen können. Jetzt wird er immer toller und schöner. Völlig Gegenteil ist eingetreten. Heutzutage wird der Computer nicht mehr im Ansatz verstanden, aber genutzt bis zum Exzess. Ich möchte das philosophische Problem nochmal ansprechen. Wir haben in der Menschheitsgeschichte noch niemals ein Medium gehabt oder ein Werkzeug, bei dem wir Daten weitergeben können, unverfälscht, ohne sie zu filtern, im gleichen Umfang, in der gleichen Masse, ohne sie zu beeinträchtigen, zu verkleinern oder zu verbessern. Das heißt, wir können Computer weitergeben, die Daten bleiben für die nächste Generation erhalten und sie muss auf Gedähe und Verderb sie nutzen. Also wir können zum ersten Mal, möchte ich mal sagen, Wissen weitergeben, ohne dass es jemand lesen muss, interpretieren muss. Das Wissen wird eins zu eins in die nächste Generation geschoben. Ich sage jetzt Wissen in Anführungszeiten.
Es wird schon verarbeitet, aber das erzeugt wieder Wissen, das weitergeschoben wird.
Es wird aber eigentlich nur genutzt. Siehe Wiki, wie viele Leute schauen. Also Wiki ist geil, mache ich selber auch mit, wie wahrscheinlich jeder, aber Wiki wird so oft als Wissen genutzt von Leuten, die sich dieses Wissen nur zur Nutze machen und sich nicht erarbeiten und damit gar nicht verstehen, was sie damit machen, wenn sie es anwenden. Im Prinzip ist das wie Abschreiben in der Schule.
Da sehe ich den Zenit des Internets jetzt langsam überschritten. Man ist jetzt nicht mehr der gängigen Meinung, im Internet steht immer die Wahrheit. Alles, was elektronisch ist, ist wahr. Nicht? Das war ja mal so. Man ging ja ins Internet und suchte und so muss das sein. Aber inzwischen ist es auch in der breiten Bevölkerung klar, dass wenn ich im Internet etwas finde, dann muss es nicht unbedingt richtig oder wahr sein.
Man muss es x-mal finden und Querverbindungen suchen.
Man macht eigentlich heuristische Ermittlungen.
Dafür ist es dann gut.
Dafür ist es dann vielleicht gut. Aber noch mal zu dem anderen Problem.
Wir schleppen Dinge mit Zeitungen, wo man glaub ich immer noch glaubt, dass es wahr ist.
Im Prinzip sind wir jetzt bei dem, wo ich vorhin angefangen hab.
Aber ich muss interpretieren. Eine Zeitung zerfällt irgendwann zu Staub. Meine Kinder müssen es weiter erzählen. Das heisst, sie haben das bereits interpretiert. Aber ein Speicher zerfällt nicht zu Staub. Der bleibt eins zu eins. Ich nehm alles mit. Egal wie viel Hintertürchen. Ich geh jetzt mal in Richtung Hacker wieder. Der erste Programmierer, der eingebaut hat. Wenn in 200 Jahren einer dieses Programm benutzt, wird er eins zu eins diese Daten mitschleppen und benutzen. So ein Medium hatten wir nie. Bücher sind zerfallen. Bücher musste man lesen.
Was ist dann die Auswirkung davon?
Die Auswirkung ist, dass wir irgendwann eine Art Datenmüllentsorger brauchen. Dass wir nicht mehr wissen, wie viel Daten wir noch haben. Oder beziehungsweise wir werden nur noch Suchmaschinen haben, die versuchen aus dem Datenmüll das zu finden, was wir brauchen. Wenn sie sich anschauen, sie gehen jetzt in den Media-Markt, kaufen sich Terabyte-Festplatten, stapelweise. Mein Sohn hat die inzwischen auch irgendwo rumliegen. Jeder kopiert Daten drauf, unbesehen.
Es werden Fotos gemacht. Und auf lange Sicht kommt dann eigentlich wieder die Selektor-Funktion rein, weil normale Zeitungen sind im Prinzip nichts anderes als Informationsselektoren. Das ist durch Internetmedien oder Netzmedien generell völlig aufgehoben. Es wird nicht mehr selektiert. Der Einzelne muss selektieren, der Einzelne ist aber überfordert. Also wird es durch eine Hintertür wieder Selektoren geben, die sich aus irgendeinem Grunde als vertrauenswürdiger weisen. Und dieser Prozess ist halt noch lange nicht abgeschlossen. Da würde ich auch nichts bewerten.
Also wir brauchen eine Datenmüllverbrennungsanlage sozusagen.
Ich glaube, dass wir immer intelligentere Sicht auf die immer mehrwerten Daten brauchen.
Das wäre ein Wunschtraum. In Wahrheit glaube ich, wir laufen als Gesamtsgesellschaft dahin.
Also da haben wir ja heute einen interessanten Tag erreicht. Also heute ist der 2. Mai irgendwie. Gestern hat Herr Wolfram, der Mathematiker geschrieben hat, seine Wolfram-Alpha-Maschine vorgestellt. Sie ist nun nicht online, man kann sie noch nicht testen. Aber das ist ja das System, was im Prinzip verspricht, das Wissen der Welt mathematisch erschließbar und damit...
Versprechungen glaube ich nichts.
Ich lasse mal ganz offen, ob das jetzt funktioniert oder nicht. Aber nur wenn man mal annehmen würde, es würde tatsächlich das tun, was er sagt, so wäre das dann nicht sozusagen das, was wir brauchen, so das automatisierte System, was irgendwie uns Auskunft gibt.
Wer steuert dieses System?
Wer programmiert dieses System? Und warum habe ich dann einen Hirn?
Na, ihr fragt es zu sehr nach einem Lösungsmittel durch die Maschine. Das Problem ist ein gesellschaftliches. Wir reden im Moment darüber, dass Arbeitnehmer lebenslang lernen sollen und so ein Scheiß. Früher hat man was gelernt. Und das Lernen hat nicht mit der Ende der Lehre aufgehört, sondern man hat gearbeitet und dabei weiter gelernt. Man hat einen Kopf eingeschaltet, wenn man gearbeitet hat. Im Prinzip bewegen wir als Gesamtgesellschaft auf dieses Nicht-Lernen zu, sondern es wird Wissen angehäuft und bei Bedarf aus diesem Haufen zur Nutzung abgerufen, aber nicht, um es zu reflektieren und weiterzuentwickeln. Das heisst, die Gesellschaft wird durch diesen statischen Wissenspool, durch die unheimliche Menge, die immer grösser wird und immer statischer wird, weil es kommt immer nur ein Layer außenrum dazu, wird die Gesellschaft in sich wissensstatisch. Es wird immer weniger Fortentwicklung geben, weil du ja für dein normales Umfeld das Wissen aus dem Netz holst und verwendest und zu keinem Zeitpunkt nur Wissen in einem Buch holst und erst mal verstehen musst, damit du es auf dein Thema anwenden kannst. Sondern du holst es als nutzbares Stück raus. Da gibt es einen wunderschönen Roman oder eine Serie-Romane von... Jetzt müsste ich im Internet nachschlagen. Aha. Von einem Outline-Science-Future-Romane. Eine seiner Theorien ist übrigens ein Wissenschaftler. Eine seiner Theorien ist, es wird in Zukunft den neuen Beruf des Software-Archaeologen geben. Das heißt, es werden für neue Anwendungen gar keine neuen Programme mehr geschrieben, sondern er geht davon aus, dass nach mehreren hundert bis tausend Jahren Entwicklung jedes Problem schon mal mehrfach gelöst wurde. Und es wird gar kein Geld ausgegeben für eine neue Lösung, sondern es wird Geld ausgegeben, um in Archiven bestehende Lösungen zu finden und die vielleicht auf die aktuelle Maschine zu adaptieren und das Interface ein bisschen zu ändern.
Da muss ich aber als Musiker dazwischen geigen und sagen, das kenne ich aus der Musik auch. Da hat auch irgendjemand vorgerechnet, es wäre jede Melodie, der hat gemeint Tonfolge, das lacht jeder Musiker.
Moment, der hat wahrscheinlich schon mal Bowlen gehört.
Das war alles schon mal da.
Es war alles schon mal da und deswegen könnte es nichts Neues geben und da hocke ich halt als Instrumentenbauer und sage bei meiner Haarfilm.
Ja, aber da spielt jeder, wenn du Haarfilm spielst, spielst du wieder was Neues.
Richtig.
Hier geht es darum, du liest Wiki und nimmst es so her, wie es ist, und du denkst nicht nach.
Nein, das ist die falsche Denkvorstellung, eine Tonfolge für Musik zu halten. Und das ist im Computerbereich ähnlich. Also die Variationsbreite ist unendlich in der Musik wie im Computerbereich.
Kommen wir mal wieder zurück zur BHP. Vollkommen gerechtfertigte philosophische Ausflüge zu machen, finde ich auch sehr interessant. Ich wollte nochmal auf was kommen, was sozusagen hier auch so konkretes archäologische Heritage ist von der BHP, neben den Ausgaben. Wie viel gab es? Es gab 13 Ausgaben, ja, durchnummeriert bis zu 15. Aber ihr habt euch, glaube ich, für das oktale Zahlensystem entschieden.
Also es gibt 15 oktale Ausgaben. Das sind 16 oktale Ausgaben, weil es gab die 13 in zwei Varianten. Natürlich, wenn man Dezimal zählt, gibt es die 8 und 9 nicht. Das heißt, Dezimal wären das Ganze nur 13 bzw. 14 Ausgaben. Wenn man dazu noch die zwei Sonderausgaben...
Wieso gab es die 2-mal?
Oh, oh, oh, das ist jetzt fast wieder schnittwürdig. Das ist ein kleines dunkles Geheimnis. Die BHP wurde mal verkauft. Es wurde eine 13a gemacht von jemand, der dann darin Werbung eingefügt hat für einen Modemverkäufer. Und der, der Zugriff auf die Abonnentenbasis hatte, dorthin geschickt hat. Wir haben uns alle eigentlich nicht richtig geärgert, sondern wo es passiert ist, haben wir uns amüsiert, weil wir uns an der Stelle selbst gehackt haben.
Das war ein Unfall?
Ja, wir wollten keine Werbung haben. Es wurde tatsächlich Gold angeboten, dass wir Werbung machen. Wenn die BHP, die für nichts Werbung macht, plötzlich einen Modem anpreist, hat er sich erhofft, dass kräftig das Modem gekauft wird. Wenn die Freaks das haben, werden es die anderen auch kaufen. Das Modem war übrigens völlige Scheiße. 300 Bote Modem zu einem Zeitpunkt, als jeder Normalmensch schon 2 Vierer hat. Also Normalmensch wie wir.
So ganz normale Computerzeitungsgründe in den 80er-Jahren.
Wie gesagt, die Numerierung ist diskussionswürdig.
Gut, wie auch immer. Die Seiten waren dann auch passend hexadezimal durchgezählt, damit es sich auch wirklich niemanden ohne Weiteres erschließt. So kann man ja dann auch immer seine Zielgruppe ganz gut markieren.
Moment, die waren einwandfrei mit Dollar markiert.
Ich sage ja gar nichts, wie auch immer. Ich glaube, und ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, aber ich glaube, das war das Erste, was ich aus dem BHP-Kulturkreis wahrgenommen habe, war die Definition der Programmiersprache vatikal, Untertitel die Apokalypse der Programmiersprachen. Ich halte hier auch gerade ein Häftchen, ein ausführliches in meiner Hand. Sprachdefinition und Bedienungsanleitung. Und vielleicht zitiere ich nochmal kurz. Vatikal erschien im Jahre des Herrn 1983 als Kreation der legendären Häuser Kashiware und Gradlersoft und erhielt 1984 trotz Bedenken, ansonsten gut informierter Kreise die Serienreife. Ich will das jetzt nicht komplett vorlesen, aber es handelt sich hierbei um eine sehr lustige Ausführung über eine fiktive Programmiersprache, die meines Wissens so nie implementiert wurde, oder?
Wir haben das Ding rausgebracht und es hat Leute gegeben, die haben das auf dem C64 implementiert. Wichtig ist, wenn du auf der letzten Seite liest, die Definition ist bewusst inkompatibel zu jeder möglichen, oder so ähnlich steht es drin, zu jeder möglichen Implementierung. Und falls es doch jemand implementiert wird, wird es eine neue Version geben, die wiederum inkompatibel ist. Ganz wichtig.
Okay, wer hat sich das ausgedacht? Was ist die Geschichte von Vatikal?
Auch das ist ein klassischer Stammtisch-Thema gewesen. Man muss sagen, es gab diesen Montags-Stammtisch in der Tvenning Parade, eben wieder in dieser Behinderungswohnanlage, wo mehr oder weniger der Kern der BHP zusammengekommen ist. Mehr oder weniger ganz einfach deswegen, weil es eben diese Wolkenbildung bei uns gab. Es gibt kein zentrales Redaktionsteam, es gibt niemand, der sagen kann, der ist dabei oder nicht. Weil wir haben nie eine Organisation angestrebt. Weil wenn ich mich einer Organisation unterwerfe, verliere ich meine Freiheit. Entweder arbeite ich als freies Wesen gemeinsam an einem Thema.
Dann höre ich auf, als systemische Entität zu existieren.
Das klingt jetzt unheimlich theoretisch, aber wir haben es einfach gelebt. Ein gutes Bier und ein Schnitzel-Pommes macht das auf dem Stammtisch weg. Und an dem Stammtisch sind natürlich sehr viele technische Sachen besprochen worden. Da sind ganz ernsthafte Sachen gemacht worden. Da sind Sachen geworden, die wirklich von irgendeiner kleinen I.O.-Schaltung bis zur Infrarot-Steuerung von einer Rakete gegangen sind. Entschuldigung, das ist heute Terroristenwissen, damals war es Technik. Und es sind natürlich auch Sachen passiert, die so ganz leicht daneben gerutscht sind. Und da gehört zum Beispiel die Entwicklung von Vatical dazu. Es war einfach unheimlich fordernd und fördernd zu überlegen, wie kann denn eine wirklich seligmachende Programmiersprache sein?
Aber irgendjemand scheint es mittlerweile im Vatical implementiert zu haben.
Man weiß es nicht. Vor allen Dingen das Zentrale ist hier, wir haben uns von dem Thema auch der Hardware, RAM und ROM und sowas gelöst und haben ganz wichtig die ewige Liste eingeführt. Die ewige Liste ist etwas, was seit unendlichen Zeiten und in unendliche Zeiten geführt wird und alles definiert, was das System darstellt. Jede Eingabe und Fehleingabe, die du je machst, landet in der ewigen Liste. Alle Variablen, die du definierst, sind in der ewigen Liste. Die ewige Liste ist übrigens als warm angelegt.
Kann weder überschrieben noch gelöscht werden, heißt es hier.
Genau.
Allenfalls der Befehl Doomsday erstellt eine kommentierte Liste der erfolgten Eingaben und lässt vertikal entsprechende Entscheidungen treffen, die sich nicht unbedingt mit Absicht und Willen des Benutzers decken müssen. Ich meine, sowas kann ja nicht nur aus Bayern kommen. Es scheint ja wirklich so die Urkritik gegenüber dem allumfassenden katholischen Präsenz zu sein, oder?
Bayern ist ein katholisches Land. Wir sind gern in einer katholischen Umgebung, auch wenn der Großteil der Bayern nicht unbedingt mit der Linie der katholischen Kirche übereinstimmt.
Das war auch noch nie so. Genau.
Es sind wirklich großartige Sachen da drin, allein die variablen Namenbezeichnungen, die sich dann, je nachdem, was für Variablen es sich handelt, aus unterschiedlichen Namensräumen von Namen von Heiligen, aus unterschiedlichen Zeiträumen zusammensetzen. Das kam dann irgendwann raus, und es ist der totale Renner geworden. Es ist so der, wie soll ich sagen, es war einfach eine super Reflektion des damals so existierenden Humors in dieser Szene, dass man sich vor allem auch selbst nicht zu ernst mit den ganzen Sachen. So kam es zumindest bei mir an.
So ist es ja auch. Ich meine, die am wenigsten Ernsten waren mir selber. Das einzige Ernsthafte war Axel, wenn er uns gemahnt hat, dass wir doch endlich mal eine Ausgabe fertig kriegen sollten. Das war auch so, wir haben uns zum Beispiel kein Ausgabengerüst übergestülpt. Es ist eine Nummer fertig geworden, wenn wir eine Nummer fertig hatten. Es gab teilweise Themen, da haben wir nach zwei Monaten die nächste Nummer fertig gehabt.
Das ist jetzt deine Ausrede, weil du den Bavarstein nie abgeliefert hast. Entschuldigung. Axel hat irgendwann gesagt, jetzt ist eigentlich Zeit, jetzt machen wir wieder eine. Dann ist Hans Ewig mit seinem Zeug nicht hergekommen. Deswegen hat es selten welche gegeben.
Mehr Kulper, mehr Maxima Kulper.
Vatikal.
Oder muss ich jetzt reformieren?
Das wollen wir jetzt nicht vertiefen.
Wir tragen das alles in die ewige Liste ein. Das wird dann später von den Datenarchäologen...
Zum Glück gibt es noch den Doomsday-Befehl.
Ja.
Das andere Sonderheft, was auch großen Einfluss hatte, war der NuA-Guide. NuA sind die IDs, die Anwahlkennungen für Rechner im Datix P-Netz gewesen.
Network User Authentication. Also die sozusagen, was man heute als URLs auffassen würde.
Oder als IP-Adresse. Einwahlpunkte. Kann man mit heutigen Berufen nicht vergleichen.
Und da haben wir in der Frühzeit, ich glaube, das war auch 1984 oder 1984, haben wir im Prinzip das erste brauchbare Verzeichnis deutschlandweit aufgestellt, weil wir Daten sammeln. Von der Post selber gab es ja im Prinzip ein Datex-P-Telefonbuch, was sich dadurch auszeichnete, dass viele Einträge dabei waren und fast keiner eine Nummer enthielt. Also man muss sich mal aus heutiger Sicht diese Perversion vorstellen. Die Post gibt ein, also Telekom wäre das heute, gibt ein Telefonbuch raus, wo alle Namen und Adressen der Anschlussinhaber drinsteht und keine Telefonnummer dazu. Oder vielleicht bei jedem Hundertsten eine Telefonnummer dazu. Und das war irgendwie untragbar. Solche Listen sind in den Mailboxen rumgelaufen, man hat getauscht, ich habe wieder einen neuen Rechner gefunden. Und wir haben halt versucht, das aus verschiedenen Quellen zusammenzufahren, mit eigenen Recherchen zu erweitern und haben damit im Prinzip das erste Telefonbuch, allgemein zugängliche Telefonbuch des Datex B gemacht.
Da waren aber jetzt nur die Adressen drin. Nicht die Nuys, nicht die Zugangsnummern.
Nein, da waren nur die Adressen drin.
Das haben wir auch ganz fleißig getauscht.
Das ist was anderes. Die Zugangsnummern, bitte, das muss jeder für sich wissen. Hat man ja auch leicht gekriegt. Ich meine, hast du ja ganz normal auch Zugang kriegen können ins Datex-P-Netz.
Dann gab es irgendwie auch noch eine Doppelausgabe mit der Datenschleuder. Was hat es damit aufgetragen?
Ja, das war IFA 85. Zur Internationalen Funkausstellung 85 haben wir eine gemeinsame Nummer mit der Datenschleuder gemacht. Eigentlich andersherum, die Hamburger haben uns angeboten, wollen sie nicht mitmachen, machen sie eine Seite bei uns mit. Weil wir wollen einen Heftel machen und wir kriegen es nicht voll als Sondernummer. Ja, haben wir gesagt, logisch, machen wir mit. Das ist übrigens ein Experiment, wenn man das anschaut. Das Layout dafür ist sehr hochwertig, weil wir damals hatten einen Zugang zu einem der allerersten PC-basierten DTP-Systeme, die direkt in der Belichtungsvorstufe arbeiten konnten. Damals auf einem Sirius basiert. Das ist noch aus der Vor-EBM-Zeit. Sirius ist ein 8086 basierter Rechner entwickelt von Chuck Petl, der damals auch den PET gemacht hat. Und haben das da gelayoutet in Heidelberg wirklich zwischen Tür und Angel. Und haben die Daten dann an Hamburg als Ausdruck ausgeliefert, die das eingefügt haben. Komplett gelayoutete Seite. Da hat es in Hamburg auch große Augen gegeben. Paradigmenwechsel. Wir haben die ganzen Ausgaben immer versucht, das Layout zu verbessern und die Druckqualität zu verbessern, ohne das, was gut ist, herzugeben, nämlich Papier und Schere. Wichtig aber ist jetzt nur, wir haben dann kurz noch vor Ende, ich muss eigentlich sagen, war sogar ich, den Gag eingebaut, dass wir ins Impressum, was wir drauf hatten, reingeschrieben haben. Ich muss jetzt aus dem Gedächtnis schämen, so in der Art, dies ist, nein Entschuldigung, im Intro war es, obwohl viele das denken, dies ist nicht die Rückseite der Datenschleuder, sondern dies ist die Vorderseite des Hefts. Und wo wir das ganze dann abgegeben haben, hat, wer immer die Schlussredaktion gemacht hat, und ich denke, das war Wao selber damals, hat wirklich blitzschnell reagiert und in seinem typischen Humor das Impressum der Datenschleuder-Seite-Teil geändert und hat nicht nur im Datenschleuder geschämt, sondern dreiseitige Rückseite der BHP. Wo das Ganze wieder gedruckt war, die Hamburger haben das kopieren übernommen. In Berlin, glaube ich, sogar dann. Wo das Ganze dann wieder in unseren Händen war, haben wir natürlich geblendet und irgendwann haben wir draufgeschaut und wir sind verlachen umgefallen. Das ist bis heute für mich der beste Witz, der je aus Hamburg gekommen ist. Es ist einfach zum Brüllen komisch gewesen.
Genau, die dreiseitige Rückseite der bayerischen Hackerpost steht hier drauf. Impressum. Ja, ich glaube, das war Vau, so wie sich das hier liest. Ja, es quietschen die Türen. Wir sind ja hier gerade sozusagen unterhalb des Vintage-Festivals, während oben an den alten Geräten herumgeschraubt wird. Wir sitzen hier im stillen Kämmerlein und unterhalten uns. Über die BHP, die ja eigentlich doch ein recht kurzes Projekt war. Also es ging von 1984 bis, wann war Ende 1988? Also wenn man der Wikipedia-Glauben mag, dann ging es bis 1988. Und danach hat sich, wie so, was was dann passiert, also hat sich dann irgendwie alles aufgelöst?
Ja, es war ja so, auch wenn es hier die Verschwörungstheorie gibt, dass alles am Hans seine Schuld ist. Ich meine, Grundformel IHF, it's Hans fault, aber abgesehen davon...
Also deine Schuld sozusagen. Ja, natürlich.
Jürgen, der eine muss es auf sich nehmen und ich bin breit gebaut. Es ist also, die BHP ist wirklich nur entstanden, wenn wir Material zusammen hatten und wenn wir Lust hatten. Ab der Nummer 5 habe ich im Prinzip die Schlussredaktion übernommen. Und da gab es dann auch Ausgaben, die ich im Prinzip von vorn bis hinten selber bestritten habe. Weil manchmal wirklich nichts gegangen ist. Und zum Beispiel einer der Termine war, wir wollten eigentlich immer zum CCC-Kongress fertig werden. Wenigstens eine Nummer haben. Hat auch meist irgendwie geklappt. Ich erinnere mich an eine Ausgabe, wo wir beim Freund im Büro, sein Büro über die gesamten Weihnachtsfeiertage in Beschlag genommen haben, um irgendwie eine Ausgabe zu machen. Es ist dann so gewesen, dass 87, 88 eine ganze Reihe Leute weggezogen sind, beruflich anderes gemacht haben. Und damit ist an der Stelle die Kommunikation schwierig geworden. Wir hatten wenigstens noch über zwei Jahre eine halbe Nummer immer in Vorbereitung, bis es dann wirklich eingeschlafen ist. Aber bis heute ist es nie eingestellt worden. Wir haben ja unregelmäßige Erscheinungszeitrahmen. Ob ein Monat, zwei Monate oder ein Jahr zwischen zwei Heften, hat es alles während der Erscheinung gegeben. Dann sind halt jetzt mal 24 Jahre dazwischen.
Das heißt, es kommt wieder eine neue Ausgabe?
Jetzt bringe ich die Version für die Verschwörungstheoretiker. Wir sind irgendwann auf den Adam Weishaupt gestoßen aus Ingolstadt. Oha. Und haben uns gedacht, das wäre doch geil, wenn wir das auch machen. Wir tauchen einfach ab.
Und?
Dann haben wir ausprobiert.
Also kommt jetzt noch eine Ausgabe von der BHP oder nicht?
Wenn wir das sagen, dann müssten wir dich anschließend erschießen. Nein, ganz ernsthaft. Geplant war eigentlich, dass wir jetzt hier zu diesem Festival nicht nur eine Reunion machen nach 25 Jahren, sondern auch eine neue BHP-Ausgabe. Und da ist jetzt leider der Unfall mit Axel wirklich in den Weg gekommen. Vor allen Dingen, wir wollten nicht einfach nur wieder ein neues Heftchen zusammensetzen, sondern zum einen sollte die Stoßrichtung wieder ein bisschen aktualisiert werden. Das heißt, es sollte noch mehr auf das Thema erlebbare, machbare Technik und Technikeinfluss heute, sodass es auch die Nicht-Techniker verstehen. Also den gesellschaftlichen Technikeinfluss für Nicht-Techniker.
So gut als möglich halt.
Wir zielen immer auch auf den Nicht-Freak.
Auch für den soll es unterhaltsam sein.
Theoretisch sollte sogar die Frau Merkel das lesen können. Ob sie es abonnieren will, aber wir würden ihr sogar ein kostenloses Abo geben.
Inwieweit sie es versteht, ist natürlich eine andere Frage.
Moment, wir verstehen es ja selber nicht. Wenn wir es verstehen würden, bräuchten wir es ja nicht drucken. Oh, schneiden, bitte schneiden. Genau, ich verlasse mich auf dich. Die zusätzlich arbeitet Peter Führter Thomas auch an einem Experiment, wie wir die BHP ins Internet bringen. Das ist aber jetzt noch in Arbeit. Wobei wir nicht einfach nur das Übliche machen wollen, dass wir irgendwie drei Spalten Layout mit Werbung links und Menü rechts haben. Und dabei dann irgendwie in der Mitte den redaktionellen Test zwischen ein paar Flashboxen und Pop-ups unterbringen, weil das ist ja so die normale Redaktionsgestaltung, oder dass wir irgendeinen Blog draus machen, sondern wir versuchen, was Neues an der Stelle zu verwirklichen, was wirklich das, was gut ist an einem Print-Medium, nämlich Artikelorganisation, Artikel-Layout, in die doch ganz anderen Sehgewohnheiten des Web, also des Computerbildschirms, zu bringen. Es ist eine neue Versuch, eine Synthese zu bilden. Und ich würde da einfach bitten, dass die Leute uns noch eine kleine Idee Zeit geben, bis wir die Verzögerungen aufgeholt haben. Und dann ein paar schöne Spielereien. Und es ist einfach mal ein Versuch, wirklich zu sagen, was ist gut am Print-Medium, was einfach mit dem ganzen Web verloren gegangen ist, und was ist am Web gut, und wie kann ich die zwei Sachen jetzt vielleicht neu anstoßen.
Aber ihr wollt das dann auch schon nochmal drohen?
Ja, es wird beides sein.
Ich arbeite speziell dran, dass man eine Online-Ausgabe einfach vor sich hat, die einfach über die Browser-Druckfunktion ausgedruckt werden kann, als wäre es, zumindest fast, ein ähnlich wie damals gedrucktes Medium. Wünschen würde ich mir halt noch jemanden, der mit XSL-Effort auskennt.
Das wollen wir alle haben.
Ich kann das halt nicht auch noch machen.
Auch wenn wir bodenständig sind, sind wir ja nicht rückständig.
Ganz im Gegenteil.
Ja, das Einzige, was ich mir hier noch notiert hatte, was wir jetzt noch nicht erwähnt haben, was war das mit dem BHP-Informationsdienst und Tschernobyl?
Ach so, das war eigentlich so eine Aktion, da haben wir mal kurz unsere Muskeln spielen lassen, also außerhalb von diesem Print-Medium. Man erinnert sich ja jeder, Tschernobyl war Informationssperre von oben.
Also 1986, als es die Hochgang war.
Gut, und dann haben sich halt ein paar Leute hier auf die Socken gemacht und wir haben erstmal von Münchner Instituten und privaten und universitären Instituten Messergebnisse gesammelt und haben über die damals verfügbaren Datennetze, das waren ja nicht viele, damals öffentlich verfügbaren Datennetze, also Geonet, ComVox gab es, Cerberus vor allen Dingen, Cerberus gab es als Netz noch nicht, das war praktisch in Folge dann. Per Hand die Schnittstellen zu diversen Redaktionen und so aufgemacht und praktisch erste Messdaten und Listen von Instituten weitergegeben, die Messdaten erstellen.
Zur nach Deutschland eingetragenen Radioaktivität.
Und damit konnten wir eigentlich diese Informationssperre, die hier von Zimmermann CSU speziell in Bayern errichtet wurde und unter Kohl einfach festgehalten wurde. Über die Medien hast du nichts erfahren, überhaupt nichts damals.
Ja, im Tschernobyl ist was hochgegangen. Also was man heute alles sieht, die Bilder, die hast du damals nicht gesehen. Sondern es wurde wirklich erzählt, wirklich gleich Stunden später haben sie uns schon erzählt, da geht sowieso nichts raus. Und ein paar Stunden später wurde uns erzählt, uns Bürgern. Ja, der Wind weht ja eh immer nach Osten. Und wenn Wasser verweht, sind ganz kurzlegige Elemente, noch bevor es regnet, sind die schon wieder zerfallen. Leider in andere strahlende Elemente, ja? Das hat dann wieder keiner gesagt. Und es hat Gegenden in Deutschland gegeben, die nicht nur schwer messbar, sondern wirklich ganz deutlich messbare Belastungen hatten, die wurden nicht erzählt. Wir wurden hier doof gehalten. Und die einzigen, die noch döfer gehalten wurden als wir im Westen, waren die im Osten. Denen wurde erst mal gar nicht erzählt, dass der Reaktor überhaupt hochgegangen ist.
Und entsprechend haben wir halt eben verfügbare Messdaten gesammelt, private Netze aktiviert, Listen zusammengestellt mit Instituten, die selber Messungen erstellen, Verhaltenstipps zusammengestellt, wie man sich am besten verhält.
Und haben versucht, dass das Ganze dann eben an Printmedien, Redaktionen rangeht.
Und das Ganze über die damaligen Datennetze verteilt. Und das hat auch funktioniert.
Man hat gemerkt, wie nach ungefähr 14 Tagen hat es plötzlich angefangen, dass es einzelne Artikel gab, die von dieser inoffiziell gesetzten Regierungslinie, anders kann man es nicht nennen, ich glaube nicht an Verschwörungstheorien, das war auch keine Verschwörung, sondern das war einfach nur kompetente Unfähigkeit, abgewichen sind. Und wo du gemerkt hast, der Redaktor, der der das geschrieben hat, der Autor, muss irgendeinen unserer Infobriefe gekriegt haben, weil er irgendwo eine Idee aufgreift. Und das hat sich dann innerhalb von wenigen Wochen so weit verbreitet, dass nach zwei Monaten die Regierungslinie überhaupt nicht mehr zu halten war. Und damit war dann Tschernobyl wirklich im Bewusstsein als die Katastrophe, die es war.
Das heißt, ihr geht schon davon aus, dass sozusagen diese Informationskette, die ihr dort ausgelöst habt, auch quasi einen Medienwandel herbeigeführt hat?
Das ist einfach die Kettenreaktion, die bei sowas dann passiert.
Ich meine, wir waren nicht die Einzigen. Wir haben versucht, das vorwärts zu treiben. Gelebt hat das durch sehr viele Leute, die mitgemacht haben. Ein Netzwerk besteht nicht aus einer Handvoll Leute, die sagen, wir sind Netzwerk, sondern ein Netzwerk besteht aus vielen, vielen Punkten, die verknüpft werden. Und da können eine Handvoll Leute vielleicht helfen.
Aber Sie meinen sozusagen konkret die Mailbox-Netze in Deutschland, die da sozusagen das erste Mal die Informationen fragen?
Nein, das muss man entscheiden. Das waren damals die Datex-P-Netze, die wir aktiv benutzt haben. Und ich glaube, das war in der Richtung auch die erste aktive, aggressive Mediennutzung. Das hatte ja nichts mit Hacken zu tun. Das war einfach eine ganz, ganz legale Nutzung. Wir haben Informationen verbreitet. Und die Mailbox-Netze sind eigentlich als Folge davon entstanden, weil dadurch ein unheimlicher Willensstub oder Motivationsstub gekommen ist, sich von den offiziellen und staatlich kontrollierten Informationskanälen selbstständig zu machen und auch nicht abhängig zu sein von den großen Datex-P-Boxen, sondern das gleich selber zu machen.
Muss man natürlich auch nicht so hochheitlich erzählen. Es haben auch viele Journalisten entdeckt, da gibt es ja neue Wege, wo ich Informationen kriegen kann. Nicht jetzt subversiv, sondern einfach nur, oh, da gibt es ganz andere Arten der Quellen. Und dann hast du wirklich in der Folge gemerkt, wie viele Journalisten, die vorher nicht mal wussten, warum der Computer eingeschaltet wird, angefangen haben, online zu gehen. Die, die vorher gesagt haben, das ist ja Techno-Freaks, das ist was für Kulturschänder oder sonst was, die haben plötzlich angefangen, oh, wie geht denn das? Wir haben in der Folge dermaßen viele Anfragen auch von Journalisten gekriegt. Helft uns doch mal, in die Datennetze zu kommen. Und zwar jetzt nicht in dem Sinne von, wir machen eine Hacker-Story, sondern im Sinne von, wo finde ich denn Informationen?
Oder wo finde ich denn was darüber? Und wie gesagt, die Mailbox-Netze in der späteren Ausformung ab 86 bis 90 waren letztlich eine direkte Reaktion auch darauf, wenn man sich vollständig abhängig machen wollte und eigene Kommunikationskanäle aufbauen wollte, hat sich dann mehr oder weniger durch das WWW, die da so als Killer-Applikation drüber gekommen ist, erübrigt, weil die diese Funktion gleich mit aufgenommen hat.
Da war ja, so bisher habe ich immer viel rausgehört, so BHP war vor allem, sagen wir mal, so ein Spaßprojekt. Es muss einfach ein Spaßgetragenes Projekt sein. An der Stelle kommt ja auch ein bisschen gesellschaftliche Verantwortung mit dem Spiel.
Moment, das gehört zu Liebesbejaugen, gehört dazu.
Leben ist Leben. Und du kannst nicht leben, ohne Verantwortung zu übernehmen. Aber du solltest auch nicht leben, ohne Spaß zu haben.
Aber es ist dann auch ein Teil davon gewesen. Ich will es nur verhindern, dass man jetzt sagt, okay, alles klar, die machen so ein bisschen vertikal, und sind lustig, und ansonsten tauschen sie ihre Nummern aus, und das war's.
Wir können ihn auch anders.
Ihr konntet auch anders.
Also sind wir jetzt wieder in Bayern. Bayern ist eine lustige Gesellschaft, aber nicht sinnfrei lustig, sondern......hintersinnig?
Hintersinnig.
Und gelegentlich hinterwurzig.
Weil es gerade Hacker in Medien hieß. Wir hatten ja auch ganz in der Anfangszeit, so 83, 84, dieses Thema. Das war ja gerade die Zeit, wann sind die ersten Privatsender gekommen? Das war ungefähr dieselbe Zeit. Wann ist das Gesetz gemacht worden?
84?
Welches Gesetz?
Für die Privatsender.
Das war in Viva Berlin, war das 85, gell?
85, ja. Und das war dann nach 85 sprang gerade in München diese ganzen Sender hoch. Und die hatten natürlich Sendezeit zu füllen. Und die waren damals auch wirklich engagiert, die Leute. Privatfernsehen war jetzt nicht der Dudelsender, wie man es heute kennt, sondern wirklich auch Leute, die was versucht haben. Und dann gab es natürlich auch jede Menge Sendungen zu Technik und wurde versucht, Magazine zu hackern zu machen. Und da erinnere ich mich noch an einen Auftritt, wo wir alle mit Pappbrillen da gesessen sind. Gott, da haben wir so richtig das Bild des Medienhackers abgegeben. Muss man alles ausprobiert haben. Ja, mit Pappbrillen, so wie Panzerknacker, damit man uns nicht erkennt.
Ach so, mit solchen...
Ja, die bösen Jungs, denen man über die Schulter schaut. Weil das waren so die Wünsche der Medienleute.
Die haben sich, glaube ich, nicht signifikant geändert seitdem.
Aber es ist nicht mehr so leicht, sie zu verarschen. Es ist nicht mehr ganz so leicht, sie zu verarschen.
Na ja.
Im Prinzip sind wir ja Medienpioniere und nicht Medienhacker.
Ja, jetzt haben wir es aber, oder?
Wir können es noch ein paar Jahre weitermachen.
Wir können natürlich noch ein paar Jahre weitermachen, aber mir ging es hier darum, einen Einblick zu liefern, in die frühe bayerische Hacker-Szene, bayerische Hacker-Post. Ich bedanke mich, Thomas, Hans und Norbert, für die Ausführung. Und ja, das war es. Chaosradio Express 123. Eine interessante Nummer haben wir hier auch gefunden für diese Ausgabe.
Ich habe es doch gesagt, das waren die Illuminaten.
Und wir lassen die Verschwörungstheorien offen zur Diskussion, zum Beispiel im Blog, in den Kommentaren zu dieser Sendung. Und ja, ich sage tschüss und wir können uns alle mal verabschieden.
Wette ich.
Ja, für Gott allerseits.
Schön bayerisch. Und ich sage bis bald. Bis zum nächsten Mal bei Chaosradio Express.